Okay, let's get started.
Cool. Um so as a recap of last week, uh
we talked about multitask reinforcement
learning and how we might want to have
reinforcement learning agents not learn
just one task, but multiple different
things that might correspond to multiple
different reward functions.
And we saw that we can formulate an
aggregated MDP uh
that encapsulates all the different
tasks where you now are augmenting your
state with some sort of task descriptor,
like a prompt or a goal or just an index
corresponding what to what they should
do.
Uh and the way that this worked is we
sample some task, um
kind of run the policy in the MDP for
that task, sample another task, and so
forth. Uh and we would then get
um yeah, get a policy that could
be able to uh successfully
achieve high reward in a number of
different MDPs or
in another way to view it, a single
aggregated MDP with this augmented
state.
Uh
this is going to be a little bit
different from meta RL, so we'll see
that uh some differences here uh later
in this lecture. Uh and we also uh
somewhat briefly talked about
goal-conditioned reinforcement learning
uh and
it could just be simply viewed as a a
special case of multitask reinforcement
learning where each task is trying to
reach a goal state and the task
descriptor corresponds to that goal
state. And so if your states are images,
for example, then now you'll be passing
as input both the to the policy both the
current image and the goal image, and
you'll be trying to reach that goal
image. Or if your state, for example, is
a vector, you'll be passing in two
vectors.
And each the the task is trying to reach
some goal state uh and you can construct
different reward functions if you have
discrete states or continuous states, uh
as some sort of uh did you kind of reach
that goal or reach close to that goal.
Uh and
one of the things that's kind of nice
about this goal-conditioned formulation
of reinforcement learning is that you
can actually do it in a
self-supervised way. You don't need task
descriptors, you don't need a different
set of tasks that you've manually
defined. You can just use a bunch of
different states
uh as kind of the tasks themselves. Uh
and a lot of different tasks can be
formulated as goal-reaching tasks.
Uh
one thing to note here is it can be
pretty hard to train, um
but you'll be experimenting with uh a
simple goal-conditioned uh reinforcement
learning setting in your homework.
Okay. So, for today, uh we're going to
be talking about meta reinforcement
learning, and specifically we'll be
talking about what that problem
statement looks like, and um a class of
meta RL methods that I like to refer to
as black-box meta RL methods.
Uh we'll start to get get into um what
these methods look like, and also some
of the challenges that they face.
So, what's the problem? Like, why do we
care about meta RL?
Uh why not just do vanilla RL? So,
um say that you're trying to figure out
how to operate a coffee and espresso
machine that you've never used before.
Um
if you wanted to do that,
um
well, first, if you wanted a kind of a a
robot or a reinforcement learning agent
to do that,
uh it would probably take a lot of data,
a lot of attempts to try to figure out
how to uh make coffee, uh cuz it's a
pretty complicated task, lots of
different steps involved. Uh you have to
do those steps in sequence, um and also
the reward signal that you get for this
sort of task probably isn't going to be
super detailed.
Uh but as a human, if you were to
attempt this task, uh
probably um if you had a little bit of
instruction or some previous experience
making espresso, then you could probably
learn it in minutes, uh, or maybe even
less than a minute.
So,
if you think about reinforcement
learning, this gap between how quickly a
human could learn something
and how slowly it would take a
reinforcement learning system to learn
it, uh, this is rather unsatisfying.
And if we think about like what is the
difference between a person and a
reinforcement learning system,
uh,
one of the big differences is that
people aren't starting from scratch.
Uh, people already know how to move
objects around with their hands.
They might already know how to make
coffee in other ways or with other
machines, uh, and they can leverage, uh,
that experience and also some notion of
it like kind of like, uh, semantic
knowledge of like what to do if someone
tells you to pick up a cup and put it
somewhere, um, or to turn a knob. And
they can leverage that previous
experience in order to solve this
problem
really, really quickly in compared to
training a reinforcement learning system
from scratch.
Um, and so,
experience with similar tasks, other
espresso making machines, um,
either espresso making on other machines
or just general like motor control,
following instructions, that sort of
thing, can be very useful when trying to
solve a new task.
Um, and I mentioned this as a kind of
example with espresso making, but, um,
this sort of framework of not starting
from scratch is really general. So, uh,
it applies to robotics problems where
you want to face you're facing a new
environment or facing a new task, uh,
but it's also really faced by
many reinforcement learning systems. Um,
as another example, say you want to
solve a challenging math problem that
you haven't solved before, um, if you
have experience solving previous math
problems, then you can use that, uh, to
more quickly solve a new problem cuz
you've learned some sort of strategies
that you might be able to apply to the
new scenario.
Okay, we're framing this question of can
reinforcement learning algorithms
leverage experience from previous tasks
in order to learn a new task with less
data and less experience.
In many ways this problem is thought of
as a transfer learning problem where we
want to transfer
knowledge information experience from
previous
uh tasks to new tasks.
And there's a few different formulations
and a few different kind of problem
settings that the research community has
thought about. One is
um
kind of a fairly stand like a fairly
simple setup where you learn one task
and then want to learn a new task. And
you can just for example train on one
task and then fine-tune on the new task
and
notions of fine-tuning that we use in
supervised learning are also applicable
to reinforcement learning settings where
you could fine-tune a Q function to a
new task or fine-tune a policy to a new
task.
Although um
the
for this to work well the tasks need to
be quite similar to each other.
Um we also talked about multitask
learning and you could also use
multitask learning for transfer to new
tasks.
Uh and in particular if your task if
your prompt shares some structure if it
kind of exhibits
um if it's just like a task one task two
task three
um transfer is going to be harder but if
it's something that has a lot of
structure like pick up a water bottle
pick up a phone pick up um a pen and so
forth then uh you might actually be able
to have things transfer
what's called zero-shot without any new
experience at all uh simply by passing
that prompt to the system and having it
uh kind of act according to that prompt.
Uh and then metal learning is often
concerned with
instead of zero-shot shot transfer
something that's called few-shot
transfer where you with a little bit of
experience a few examples or a few
trials of the task, can you
uh adapt to that task.
And
essentially the difference between
multitask learning and metalearning is
that it accounts for the fact that we're
going to be trying to adapt with a small
amount of data.
And it does that during the kind of
original training process.
Uh and another way of thinking about
this is that instead of having the task
descriptor be like a prompt or an index,
uh the task descriptor might actually be
a data set itself.
Uh like a set of trials that you're
going to be adapting to uh
in the context of some policy.
Um another word for this is sometimes
in-context learning or few-shot
learning.
Now, for this to work, uh for the first
scenario to work, you must have very
similar source and target tasks.
Uh whereas in some ways that
um things get a little bit easier and a
little bit harder for number two and
number three. Um they get easier in the
sense that you no longer have to have an
extremely similar task. You that said
just have need to have a distribution of
tasks and be similar to that
distribution, such that conceivably the
new task that you're trying to solve
should be within the distribution of
things that you've the task that you've
seen during training.
Um it gets a little bit harder because
you do actually need mult- like a number
of training tasks, not just a single
training task, uh in order to get
effective transfer.
Okay.
Before we jump into meta RL, let's look
just look at a couple of few-shot
learning examples outside of RL and then
uh go back to the RL setting.
So actually I picked this example so
that it's not like trivial. There's
other test video points that are much,
much easier.
Cool. Um so that's kind of the essence
of a few-shot image classification
problem, where you have some a small
number of data points and your goal is
to classify a new data point. Um
and typically if you were to train from
scratch on just six images,
you'd have no hope of being able to
learn a classifier, especially on
high-dimensional images. But the way
that metalearning works is you can
construct other tasks for the machine
learning system to solve that have a
similar structure, like other image
classification tasks, train it to be
able to take as input a training data
set and query image
or our test input and then predict a
label
and basically constructing these
each of these few-shot learning problems
as a data point themselves.
Uh now, another example
of uh few-shot learning outside of
reinforcement learning is in-context
learning in large language models.
Uh and what this looks like is here's
just one example. There's lots of
examples of different tasks you could
do.
Um in this case, the goal is given a
sentence that's kind of poor English
input, like I eated the purple berries,
output good English input, like I ate
the purple berries. Uh gives it in this
case, I think
four or three different examples of
input outputs.
Um this is the training data set, and
the goal is for a new input be able to
predict a good output
for that for that example.
So, here's another example kind of of a
few-shot learning problem. And again,
language models get things that kind of
look like this during training. Um one
thing that's a little bit special about
language models is that this sort of
in-context learning, you don't
explicitly set up your training data set
exactly to match all of this. Um and it
turns out that a lot of the statistics
of data on the internet leads to this
kind of this this ability to react to
these few-shot examples effectively. Um
this is actually just a base model. I
think this is from GPT-3.
Uh and so, even without any additional
supervised training, you get something
like this.
Um it doesn't it's not perfect, doesn't
work all the time. Um but there's
another example of few-shot learning.
Um and then in each of these examples,
you can think of of the goal is trying
to train this sort of model that takes
as input a training data set
um and a new example X and makes a
prediction for that example uh based on
both X and on the training data.
Yeah, so the question is uh in in
context learning in LLMs, typically you
achieve this sort of model and this sort
of few-shot learning through prompting
by putting the the data set in kind of
as as context or as part of the prompt
into the model, um is that how also how
it works in meta RL? Generally, yes,
we're going to be looking at that case
in meta RL. There are actually other
methods where you can accomplish this
with well, actually with gradient
updates as well, um or with something
that looks like that looks like nearest
neighbors. Uh
the most successful method in in meta RL
looks like prompting, and so that's what
we'll be talking about uh today.
Now, let's look at a meta RL example.
So, um
say that we want to navigate mazes.
Uh and so our goal is we want to solve a
new maze.
And we're an agent that's in this maze.
We don't get to like see We actually
don't even see this top-down view. Maybe
we just have a first-person perspective.
And our goal is because this is a
reinforcement learning problem, it's not
just about outputting a label. Uh it's
actually also about collecting
experience in the environment.
And so
kind of the goal is we'd like to be able
to very quickly solve a reinforcement
learning problem, and we'll frame this
as collecting a very small training data
set of one episode or a few episodes. Um
in this case, it's kind of exploring the
maze, trying to find um where the goal
is.
Uh and then eventually, it kind of
starts in the middle right here,
explores over here, and eventually goes
to the goal right here.
And
after we explore, we'd like to be able
to have a policy that is able to solve
the maze uh just in this case just with
a single episode of experience.
Uh and again, if you were to do uh this
sort of thing from scratch that uh tries
to use just a single episode of
experience to get a policy that can
solve the task. Uh
this would be very very hard.
Uh and instead the way that meta RL um
frames this is by trying to construct uh
examples uh and try to construct kind of
a set of training environments that
facilitates this kind of fast
adaptation.
Now, in comparison to the supervised
learning scenarios like I mentioned,
we're now going to have be faced with
this exploration problem. We're not just
given a training data set and then make
a prediction based on that training data
set. We're actually constructing the
training data set ourselves with through
exploration.
And we need to figure out how best to
trade off between exploring in the
environment uh versus being able to then
solve the task. And how much time we
should spend exploring versus uh trying
to exploit what we know about the
environment.
So, this is our our goal. Um
this is what we'd like to be able to do
at test time. We'd like to be able to
quickly
uh learn a new maze.
Then, to set our agent up for success
at meta training time um before we try
to adapt to a new maze, we'll try to
learn how to efficiently explore and
solve many other MDPs that are related.
Um in this case, they can be other mazes
uh like this uh and so forth. And these
are each of the tasks that we'll be
training on in order to adapt to a new
maze.
Cool. Um the other thing uh I guess one
key assumption here is that you need to
have like these new MDPs can't be
completely different from the MDPs that
you saw before.
Uh and the way that we can think about
that is they we should have some sort of
distribution over tasks. And these new
MDPs that we're trying to adapt to
should be within the distribution of
tasks that we saw during training.
Okay.
Maze navigation is like one example of a
meta RL task. Uh there's lots of other
scenarios as well. Uh so one
um one useful scenario uh that we've
seen in robotics is being able to adapt
very quickly to different terrains,
different slopes uh for legged robot
systems. This is actually a really small
legged robot um
but is also applicable um
uh to larger legged robots as well. And
sometimes you might actually be training
on different environments in simulation
and then adapting in the real world uh
as just another environment.
Uh you could also have object
manipulation as different tasks uh as
well in manipulation scenarios. Uh and
then there's also a number of language
modeling scenarios where this is quite
applicable. Uh one example where meta RL
has been relevant is adapting to
different users with different
preferences
uh where you give examples of the kinds
of things the kinds of responses that
they want in context. Um and we'll also
later see an example in reasoning as
well.
Yeah, so the question is like what is
the key difference between
this sort of meta RL approach and
transfer learning where you're training
and then fine-tuning. Uh and
the there's a couple ways to view it.
One is that you're during this kind of
training process you're actually
explicitly optimizing for
transferability. You're optimizing for
the ability to adapt with a small data
set. And as a result of that uh you can
get much faster transfer. You can use a
much smaller data set. Uh and there are
examples of like if you use fine-tuning
versus if you use like few-shot
in-context learning or few-shot
adaptation, you can get much more
efficient transfer. Um
and yeah, so you get much greater
efficiency uh and the the way that you
get that is by providing the
algorithm with
a number of different training
uh tasks rather than like just one
training task that you're feeding off
of.
Okay. Um, so slightly more formally, uh,
we've talked about multitask learning,
um, where you try to solve multiple
tasks at once. You might try to transfer
to a new task from that. Um, but you're
not optimizing for transferability. Uh,
with transfer learning, you're trying to
solve some target task after
uh, solving some source task, uh,
typically by fine-tuning.
Uh, whereas in the meta-learning
problem, we
have experience from some training
tasks, and we want to very quickly
solve, uh, a new task.
Um, and in the reinforcement learning
scenario, these tasks are going to be
MDPs, uh, each with their own state
space, action space, dynamics, reward.
Um, and there is this kind of nice, um,
we see kind of meta-learning in
supervised learning, and there's also,
um, there's kind of a nice, uh, analogy
between the two. Uh, or the main
difference with meta RL is this
exploration challenge.
Okay. Um, and then
diving into some notation here,
uh, we can view the meta RL problem as
basically being able to, uh, with a
small amount of experience,
be able to learn a policy that can solve
the task.
And also to be able to collect this
experience itself. And so this training
data, uh, there's a couple there's two
different variants of the meta RL
problem. Um, in the first case, this can
correspond to multiple rollouts from
some exploration policy.
And instead, you could also consider
this to be, um, just actually a few time
steps from your exploration policy. Uh,
there's a bit of a continuum between
these two scenarios. You might want to
be able to adapt both online with a few
time steps, and with more and more
episodes with basically kind of a
growing data set.
Um,
but writing it kind of explicitly, uh,
as two different things here uh, to kind
of
make it clear that there are some
problem settings where you want to adapt
really quickly online within an episode
and other scenarios where you're caring
a lot more about kind of multiple trials
of experience.
The last thing that I'll mention is I've
been writing it as a kind of an
exploration policy and a task policy.
There are some scenarios where you might
train these and these might be separate
networks. There's other scenarios where
these could share parameters and
basically be the same network. So,
they don't necessarily need to be
separated like they are on this slide.
And then the last thing is in so far as
we're learning this policy that's
conditioning on a training data set, you
can sort of view this as a task
identifier
and from that standpoint we're then kind
of more in a setting that looks like
multitask learning.
So, the question is when I say that it
has the test has to be in distribution
compared to the training task is it mean
it has to be the same as one of the
training tasks or can it be a bit
different? It can be a bit different.
So,
the and we'll see examples where it is
different as well.
So,
let's talk about how to address these
problems. So,
the
the good news is that there's a kind of
a very
conceptually simple way to address this
kind of general problem statement.
The bad news is that it can be
challenging to optimize in practice and
we'll talk about some of those
challenges in a bit.
But conceptually we can essentially
uh uh
train
a sequence model
it could be a transformer, any sort of
neural network with memory, a recurrent
neural network
and
use this where we're basically
everything that's being passed into this
policy corresponds to the experience
that the agent has collected.
So, so sort of you're basically
conditioning your policy on this
training data set uh,
and then having a policy output actions
based off of the data that it's seen so
far in that MDP and then training this
um, this sort of uh, the sequence model
uh, policy
uh, across
all of the set of training MDPs that we
have.
Um, so here um, this is the current
state.
Uh, this sort of context or training
data set is going to get larger over
time as we collect more experience in
uh, in a given MDP.
Um, now a question for you. Uh, there
are a couple differences between this
and simply using a recurrent policy in a
standard RL setup.
Uh, or or using a sequence model in a
standard RL setup like using a
transformer. Um, does anyone have
thoughts on like what are some of the
differences between just between kind of
what I'm starting to talk about here
and simply using a sequence model as
your policy
uh, in kind of a standard RL setup.
Memory. Um,
yeah, so typically in um,
in RL we often don't use memory and here
we're using memory.
Um, so that's that's like that's one
thing. Um, but like compared to if we
had used memory in um, in like a
standard RL setup, what else is
different here?
Yeah, so one thing that we're doing here
is we're we're actually passing the
reward as input into the memory and so
and that's a little bit different uh,
in the sense that you're actually using
reward information from the current MDP
in order to try to get better at the
task. Uh, this also means that actually
at test time or when we're trying to
adapt to a new task, we're also going to
be using the reward. Uh, and in RL
settings often times we don't
necessarily assume that we have uh, the
reward when we're just deploying our
policy.
Okay, any So, that was kind of one main
difference. Any other differences?
Yeah. So, the question is why are we
also not passing as input the actions?
You can pass as input the actions. Uh
the it depends on
um like if your policy is mostly
deterministic, then information about
past actions could be stored in the
memory as well cuz you were predicting
you generated those actions. And so, in
those cases you don't need the actions.
If you have a more stochastic policy,
then the that sampling process won't be
necessarily in the memory and in those
cases it's good to pass as input the
actions as well.
Right. So, the the note was that the
states and actions might not be the same
for different tasks. And so, one of the
things that's different here is we're
actually training this model across
MDPs. And so, you might have a different
state and action space, you might have
different dynamics. And so, because like
one of the big differences compared to
standard RL is that we're actually Yeah,
we're training this across MDPs and
there's going to be differences in
states, actions, dynamics,
uh and rewards across those MDPs.
Cool. There's actually also one other
difference, um but the first thing that
we talked about is we're see that the
reward is passed as input, you might
also be passing as input actions, and
this is trained across multiple MDPs. Uh
and that's quite different from the
typical uh reinforcement learning setup.
Now, the second thing that's also
different is that your memory
is also going to span across multiple
episodes potentially. If you're trying
to actually learn um
not just within an episode, but learn
across episodes, then rather than having
your current policy simply have memory
within an episode, uh you will be
maintaining any sort of hidden state or
any sort of memory um not just within
your episode, but across multiple
episodes.
Um so, in terms of what this algorithm
Maybe I'll leave this up here um in case
it's useful. In In of the algorithm,
uh what this looks like is we will
uh
sample
a task or an MDP.
Uh so, maybe this let's call this MDP
uh
TI.
Uh and then we're going to run our
policy in that MDP for multiple
episodes.
So, let's say run
uh pi
uh in our task or MDP
for
n episodes.
So, this is rolling out this right here,
and it's going to have memory across
those n episodes.
Uh and then optionally, if we have if
we're using an off-policy algorithm with
a replay buffer, then we would store the
uh the episodes in
a replay buffer.
And then lastly, we're going to
optimize update our policy to optimize
the rewards.
Uh and so,
we will be
updating pi, and specifically, we
are going to be maximizing the sum of
rewards like the typical RL objective,
but it's going to be across all of the
tasks in our task distribution. So,
um we'll have
some sum over tasks I
uh in in some mini batch, uh and then
also the
uh expected sum of rewards.
Uh
So, this would be an expectation under
our policy of the sum of rewards
over
different time steps.
>> Now,
the
This is a pretty simple algorithm. Uh it
looks a lot like reinforcement learning
where simply um the main thing that's
different is that we're going to be
doing this optimization across multiple
MDPs and will be our policy will have
memory across a set of episodes. Uh
usually n usually this is going to be
pretty small. Uh because if if if it was
large, if it was like a thousand
episodes, it's going to be hard to store
that in the context of um of a model
like just cuz your memory will start to
increase uh substantially.
Um so what that looks like is you have
uh
this like neural network. Uh it has uh
multiple episodes uh
and then you'll be kind of rolling it
out for multiple episodes, taking
actions, and then you'll start
collecting for a new MDP. So you'll cut
your memory when you start to collect
for the new MDP that you've sampled.
So you sample a task, roll out the
policy for n episodes. In this case, n
equals two in this diagram.
Um under the dynamics and reward
function for that MDP.
Then store in your replay buffer.
Oftentimes, you'll have a different
replay buffer for each task.
And then up to me update your policy to
maximize the discounted return for all
tasks that you've collected for, and
then repeat this process uh in order to
continuously get a a policy that's
better at doing this sort of in-context
adaptation.
Yeah, so the question is a good
question. So does um the question is
does it know that it's starting a new
episode like at this uh position right
here? Uh you could use a positioning
coding. Uh in practice, you're also
going to have a big like a probably have
a discontinuity in your state. And so
you might just be able to see that like
your your current state is very
different from the past state. Uh and
that might also tell it. Uh but yeah,
you could have some sort of token to
also tell it that it's a new episode.
Um the question is are we randomizing S1
across the different episodes? Uh when
you're rolling out the policy, uh you
will when you start a new episode,
you'll sample that that will be a
different sample from the initial state
distribution.
Uh and so S1 I guess it's maybe a little
confusing. S1 here might be different
from S1 here. S2 is very likely
different from S2 here and so forth.
Cool. And then
the outcome of this is you'll have a
policy that should be able to adapt uh
across episodes with experience from
those episodes.
Uh and it should be able to
on its own actually decide on the best
exploration exploitation trade-off. Uh
and the best exploration exploitation
trade-off is going to depend on the
number of episodes that you give it. Uh
if if N is two, then it has two episodes
to maximize rewards as quickly as
possible. Uh and if it and if it needs
to explore, it'll explore as quickly as
possible. If N is a little bit larger,
then you've given it a little bit more
budget to um it still wants to max like
explore quickly and efficiently if it
can cuz then it can get higher rewards
later, uh but it might have slightly
more budget to explore. Uh and so you'll
get um one of the things that's like
pretty cool about this when you optimize
this whole thing end to end is that it
will make decisions on um on whether or
not to explore or to exploit. Uh and
it'll make those decisions in a way
that's informed by whatever gets it the
highest reward.
Then after this sort of training
process, after you've trained it on uh
multiple MDPs,
then you can
you can actually then roll out your
policy in a new task.
Uh so
at test time,
you will then
give it a new task. So
you're in
some new
MDP
uh
TJ
and
you can take the policy that was trained
and roll it out in
um
in that MDP. So,
roll out
pi
in
that MDP uh with those states, actions,
and rewards, and so forth. Um and so,
sample new task, roll out that policy.
You want to roll this up out for up to n
episodes. Uh if you roll it out for
longer, um all bets are off in terms of
what it might do. Uh uh
You could also
um
Yeah, you could also have a variable
number of episodes that you uh use
during training if you want it to be
able to handle variable numbers of
episodes. Um but yeah, this would be
like
uh for n episodes or for up to n
episodes.
Cool.
Um so, in terms of actually implementing
this, there's a few different
architectures and optimizers you could
use. So, you could use like a vanilla
recurrent neural network. Uh some of the
first works on meta reinforcement
learning did this.
Uh and they used um algorithms This is I
think before PPO existed or was
introduced. They used an algorithm
that's somewhat similar in nature in
terms of the assumptions as PPO.
Uh
there is also a model that uh
a paper that before transformers were
really popular used self-attention um
and also 1D convolutions. You can think
of it sort of as a transformer um and
optimize this. Uh and you can actually
note that they do also pass the actions
as input um in in this particular
scenario.
Um One other thing uh we'll talk about
this a little bit in uh a bit more
later, but you can also uh instead of
using a transformer or an RNN, you could
also use a feedforward network Um
and then average across
average the embedding. This is sometimes
called a deep set
and it's has its own benefits. It's
actually pretty computationally fast
because you can paralyze everything
and also actually surprisingly
expressive for what it can do.
So let's look at some examples. So we'll
look at this example that was using
something that's kind of a bit like a
transformer
and they were used trying to learn how
to visually navigate a maze
specifically new mazes that the agent
had never been in before.
They trained it on a thousand small
mazes
and they tested it on held out mazes
that the agent hadn't seen before. They
tested it actually on both on small
mazes and on large mazes. This is
actually a scenario where they were able
to see some extrapolation to tasks that
were outside of the distribution of what
it was trained on.
So this is what it looks like. This is
at test time and you can see that the
agent it just is like exploring around
this environment looking for where the
goal is. It only gets these images as
input.
And on the right we can see the trace of
the exploration. So it started in the
middle, explored over here, and explored
down here and eventually found the goal.
And then after that exploration episode
we're still we still have memory from
that previous episode and it's able to
using that memory it's able to then be
able to kind of go directly to the goal
um
based on this experience in that maze.
So kind of watching that again. Whoops.
Um
it's this is the first episode and so
this is kind of the first episode of
rolling out this policy.
It's choosing to explore because it
doesn't know where
where the goal is in this maze. It also
doesn't know the layout of the maze.
Uh and so we see it explore here.
And then in
in the second episode, it chooses to go
straight to the goal because it decided
that it already explored the extent of
the maze.
Uh here's an example in a larger maze.
So the agent starts over here.
Um and
it explores in the top part, doesn't see
the goal
um and realizes that this is a dead end,
it doesn't need to explore it further.
And then it ends up seeing the goal
here. And then after that, it is
it goes straight to the goal after that
first episode. And so in this
training example,
n equals 2. So they trained it just with
to be able to explore and exploit after
two episodes.
Cool. And then quantitatively, they
looked at the average time to find the
goal in both the first episode and the
second episode.
They compared to using a random policy,
which occasionally does happen upon the
goal,
and using an LSTM architecture and this
more kind of self-attention and
convolution architecture. And they found
that with the small mazes,
even within the first episode, they were
able to do a lot better than random.
That means that's because it's actually
exploring efficiently and then
eventually often finding the goal.
And then
it's able to ex- like find the goal
faster in the second episode after
learning where the goal is and about the
maze in the first episode. We also see
that it does significantly better than a
random agent in the large mazes. And in
both cases, using kind of the
self-attention architecture is better
than using an LSTM architecture, which
is another memory architecture.
Yeah, so the question is is the reward
to find the goal? And if so, why is it
optimized to find it as fast as
possible?
So the reward is to find the goal.
Uh,
I I don't remember the exact structure
of the reward. Uh,
the
it's optimized to find it quickly.
There's a couple ways that that lead to
it to optimize to find it quickly. Um,
the in this particular case, uh, I
believe they're using discounted
rewards. And so the discount factor,
um, instead of being like this, you
have, uh, you're optimizing for
discounted rewards. So there is a
discount factor right there. Uh, the
discount factor is not one. It's like
probably like 0.95 or 0.99. Uh, and so
that objective will be higher, um, if
you get the reward sooner rather than
later.
Yeah, so the question is, um, what is
past as input to the model? And yeah,
exactly. So it's it's video, uh, from
the previous episode, the actions from
the previous episode at one up basically
everything up until the current time
step, which is
any previous episodes and everything is
so far in that episode. So it's all of
the video frames and then also all of
the actions and all of the rewards, uh,
as well.
Yeah, so the question is, um, where in
the algorithm are we exploring
exploration versus exploitation? And
the,
um,
here because, um, it basically all comes
down to this objective for both of them.
And the insight is that
the the
the agent doesn't know,
um, doesn't know much about the task. It
doesn't know, well, depending on the the
training tasks, um, in this case it
doesn't know what what maze it's in. It
doesn't know the structure of the maze
and that sort of thing. And so it's
actually not even it's not
able to get high reward until it starts
to explore, until it finds like where
the goal is, for example.
Uh, and so by optimizing this end-to-end
for reward, you're incentivizing it to,
um,
like it's not going to get high reward
without exploration, essentially.
Yeah, we will talk about that at, um,
soon in like a few lectures. But yeah,
there's lots of problems here cuz if
when your policy is bad and you're not
getting good rewards, uh
it ends up being very difficult to
figure out uh a good policy.
Yeah, so the question is um
instead of
uh
doing what we're doing, could it could
we just do regular RL and then do test
time training?
Um the
So,
in some ways language models with
recurrence,
like it depends on how you view it, but
in some ways you are already doing
something that kind of looks like meta
RL if it has memory, and it basically
has the ability to adapt depending on
the kind of the task that you're giving
it. Um and then yeah, and then
one important component is if you're
doing test time compute, you're allowing
it to actually like think through the
problem. Uh now, test time compute is a
very broad term. So, on the next slide,
uh we'll talk about how you can actually
use how meta RL is relevant for test
time compute, so let's talk about that
now.
Uh so,
say that we're solving different math
math problems. This is the canonical
language model example, especially for
test time compute.
Um and one example of a math problem is
trying to show this inequality. Uh this
is actually the same I think possibly
the same math problem that Aviral showed
uh in his lecture.
And
in some ways like trying to solve this
math problem is you can think of it in
some ways as an MDP itself uh in that
there's different strategies that you
might try to take to solve this math
problem.
And
you don't know a priori what strategy is
going to help you solve that problem.
Uh like which kind of which like where
do you start? Like do you try to, for
example, do guess and check? Do you try
to uh like eliminate terms in the
equation? Uh and so forth.
And ideally, you'd be able to kind of
explore those different strategies and
then produce an answer based off of the
best strategy.
Um and
it turns out that if you give um
so, Deep Seek RL one is a language model
that uses test time compute in order to
solve math problems and if you give
our one different math problems to solve
if you give it a hard problem it kind of
thinks for a while at some point it like
cuts off its test time
the test time compute because it doesn't
want to be thinking for too long for the
user
and then it outputs some explanation for
the user.
And then also if you give it a really
easy problem like two plus two equals
question mark it actually also
kind of thinks through what the solution
might be and then gives a step-by-step
explanation for the answer.
And so this is something that is like
clearly somewhat wasteful to do probably
unless this is somehow a challenging
problem.
And so you can actually use
this notion of meta RL to try to
optimize for test time compute and if
you know that you're going to be doing
test time compute at test time then
basically bring that into the training
process and
encourage the model to efficiently use
that test time compute efficiently
explore different strategies such that
ideally on easy problems it is
trying to output an answer as quickly as
possible and for harder problems is is
thinking as much as it needs including
possible exploration
until it then tries to exploit and give
an explanation.
And so
this this paper here was a paper that
explored that they found that when they
were trying to explicitly
optimize for effective use of test time
compute they were able to get higher
performance with the same number of
tokens and also
actually reduce the number of tokens
needed to get the same performance so
that you aren't for example using up a
ton of tokens on simple problems.
So that's a use case of meta RL in
ideas for meta RL in language models.
Now a quick digression um and this will
actually
lead us into a different way of thinking
about meta RL.
So, we talked about multitask policies
where we condition on a task descriptor.
Um so, maybe we want a robot to stack in
different locations or a robot to walk
in different directions.
And we've talked about policies that
take as input experience and then kind
of generate actions based off of that
that data set.
And if you were to think about how this
relates to multitask learning policies,
one way to think about it is that
we're but just doing multitask learning,
but now this data is our task
identifier.
And this is it's something that actually
changes within a task. Um so, it's the
analogy is not perfect, it's not
actually fixed for a given task. Uh but
you could sort of thinking think about
it as conditioning on the task in so far
as experience tells you what the task
you're trying to do is.
Cool.
Um and if you think about goal condition
policies, um
rewards are like you can talk about also
view meta RL as a kind of a
generalization of goal condition
policies uh cuz
there's a set of
MDPs that are goal reaching MDPs, uh and
then there's a broader set of MDPs that
are reward maximizing MDPs.
Uh and so,
um and then the other way to think about
this is instead of trying to generalize
to new goals, you can think about meta
RL as trying to adapt uh to new tasks
with a small amount of experience. Uh
and this would be kind of the difference
between uh zero-shot generalization in
the goal condition case and K-shot
generalization with like K episodes or K
time steps in the meta RL case.
Now,
um so, we've talked about how we can
view the experience as
the task descriptors here, the prompt
essentially.
Uh but there's actually another way to
look at it, which is that if we think
about this policy with memory and that
has kind of the past memory and and our
current policy,
if we were to think about what
information is being passed right here
to the policy,
uh this information is is presumably
information about the task.
And so, and specifically um when ZI
isn't part of the state, there's
ambiguity about what MDP you're trying
to solve, and you're using that
experience to try to identify
the MDP that you're in.
Uh and you can sort of think about it as
the policy needs to infer the task, and
needs to infer specifically some sort of
latent task descriptor from its
experience.
And so, another way of looking at meta
RL is something where you are
using your experience to infer what the
task is, and then conditioning your
policy that's acting at the current time
step on um on your current estimate of
what the task is.
Uh so, you can think about it
essentially as meta RL is trying to inf-
uh explore to infer this unknown task,
and then perform the task.
I see. So, you're asking like um because
we're going to be inferring the task
identifier, why don't we just give it to
the the learning system? Yeah, so the
main reason is that we
if if we if we don't have a compact way
of describing the task that the agent is
doing, then
it may actually be like challenging like
we may not have a if we don't have a
good way to represent it, then we're not
sure what to pass into the policy.
And if we don't have a good way of
representing it, we can always resort to
just using an index saying this is task
one, this is task two, this is task
three. But if you do that, and then at
test time you say this is task 100, uh
it's not going to be able to generalize
in that scenario, and and do anything
about that scenario about that task. Uh
whereas experience like conditioning on
experience is something that could
generalize where it can actually be able
to use um
use kind of the more continuous space of
of states, rewards, and so forth in
order to figure out a new task. Um so it
comes down to representations. Uh and
you could sort of view this as like
learning a a Z representation. Uh like
learning like a continuous vector that's
representing our tasks.
Now, um in multitask RL, we talked about
how there was this um
we talked about how uh
when if you like formulate some state
space that it corresponds to the
original state space and the the the Z
vector, then you get this aggregate MDP.
Uh and so the result of this
is
uh still an MDP
uh just with a new state space and and
like new dynamics to account for this
new state space.
Uh and so there's a question of like
uh for meta RL,
is there an aggregate MDP?
And
this would be for meta RL.
in this case, we're not providing ZI in
the state.
And so there's actually like um
inherently
uh it's actually partially observed. You
don't actually know what the task is.
You're trying to explore and figure that
out from experience.
Uh and so there isn't actually an
aggregate aggregate MDP that you could
think about. Uh instead, there if you
wanted to try to aggregate it into a
single decision process, it would have
to be a partially observed MDP or a
POMDP.
Uh and it's actually a special kind of
POMDP um
where
uh we talked about before where you have
like a some sort of partially observed
Markov decision process where you can't
actually observe S.
Uh
And the you have actions and instead of
observing S, you observe some
observations
uh that are some function of S.
Uh
the
That that would be kind of the general
POMDP case. Uh one thing that's a little
bit special about um
about the meta RL thing is the only
thing that you can't observe is what the
task is.
Uh and so
it's an it's basically a POMDP where
this hidden state space can be defined
as the observation and the
task identifier.
And if you can infer the task identifier
from experience, then you can
essentially view it as a way of trying
to infer the underlying state space
uh as a way to solve the POMDP.
Um so this is basically kind of another
way of looking at uh the meta RL
problem. It's basically like a a
partially observed Markov decision
process.
Now, there's an um a meta RL method that
we actually just talked about uh we I
had showed an architecture diagram that
um that was actually explicitly trying
to output um Zs. Uh and it was actually
outputting some distribution over Zs cuz
at the very beginning you actually don't
know what Z is. Uh you have some kind of
prior belief over what Z is and then as
you get more experience, you're going to
have a better and better estimate of
what Z is. And so if you represent a
distribution over this kind of latent uh
task representation, then um
you can you can do kind of cool things
with that. Uh we'll see that in in a
bit.
Um so this uh particular algorithm was
looking at continuous control problems
uh where different tasks corresponded to
walking in different directions, running
at different velocities, uh and also
different physical dynamics. So being
able to adapt to when the friction is
different um or the inertia of of the
robot system is different.
The other thing was that
everything what we saw before was using
like a PPO so algorithm, which is uh
somewhat off policy, but not very off
policy. Uh it's kind of more on policy
than off policy in some ways cuz it's
not using a replay buffer of past data.
Um and
with meta training algorithms you can
adapt really really quickly.
Uh but the training process might be
really slow if your base algorithm is
fairly on policy.
Uh and so
as a kind of question, hopefully this
should be a straightforward question. Um
if your base algorithm for updating the
policy at step four, if that's an off
policy algorithm, do you expect that to
be more or less efficient than if you
used an off policy or than than if you
used an on policy
base method?
Yeah, more efficient. So, um if you're
using a replay buffer and using that
replay buffer to update your memory your
policy with memory, that should be a lot
more data efficient during this meta
training process. Um and then it's kind
of a test time when you're adapting, the
efficiency is going to be similar. So,
this is just talking about the the
efficiency for actually training this
sort of in-context
uh learning system.
Uh and so if you look at um if you
actually look at the curves like over
this this trading process right uh right
here, the number the amount of data that
you need in order to kind of meta learn
these kinds of systems, you can see that
in blue if we're using um
kind of an uh an off policy algorithm
with a replay buffer, it's a lot more
data efficient, learns a lot more
quickly than um
RL squared and um and PPO, which are
using I want to say all three of these
are using uh base algorithms base RL
algorithms that are more on policy, more
like PPO uh for example.
Yeah, so the question is um can I
elaborate on what specifically is in the
replay buffer. So,
uh the typically you'll have
Well, so each replay buffer will have
um
a sequence of episodes.
Basically, each thing in the in the
replay buffer will be a sequence of
episodes from a given MDP.
And
the
that includes like the the states,
the actions, the rewards.
And when you optimize this, you'll need
to Often times you'll have a different
replay buffer per task, so that you can
sample a task here
and then optimize the reward for that
task
using the the memory from that
from that that trajectory.
Typically, the buffer instead of just
storing states and actions, you're
storing full trajectories together
because you're going to be training a
model with memory. And you need to be
able to provide
that trajectory as memory as input to
the policy.
Cool. So, summary so far, we've talked
about using these models to be able to
adapt to new MDPs.
They're general, they're quite
expressive.
And there's also a variety of choices in
the architecture.
One thing is that they're hard to
optimize
because you're actually it needs to
figure out how to adapt from data. And
there's lots of like there's lots of
different input features here that you
could try to pay attention to. And the
model has to figure out what about those
like those input videos that you're
passing as input for the maze navigation
is useful when you're then trying to
exploit and learn a policy.
So, it's it's because you're passing in
so many things as input in such a big
model, it can be hard to optimize for
that reason. And it can also be hard to
optimize from an exploration standpoint,
which we'll talk about right after this.
And then
like the sample efficiency of the
meta-learning process is going to be
inherited from whatever optimizer you
use in this last step right here.
Uh and so if you use something like um
like vanilla policy gradient, it'll be
extremely data inefficient. If you use
something like PPO, it'll be more
stable, uh but still fairly inefficient.
If you use something like SAC, uh it
will be probably a lot more efficient,
uh only might need to tune the hyper
parameters more.
So, now let's talk a bit about
exploration. Uh by exploration, I mean
like uh exploration in context,
exploration uh
when you're trying to explore a new
task.
What we've talked about so far is trying
to optimize end to end for exploration
and exploitation with respect to the
final sum of rewards.
Um this simple in principle, it can
actually yield the optimal
exploration-exploitation tradeoff
because you're optimizing directly for
some of the the sum of rewards.
And that's really, really nice,
but it can be a really challenging
optimization. And let's talk about why
that's the case.
So,
um let's look at a running example. So,
say that you have uh
some robot
that looks like this. And uh the robot
needs to uh find something. Uh
and there are some hallways
uh that the robot might need to go down
in order
to try to find
uh
the thing that it's trying to find. And
different tasks correspond to uh
different locations of the object that
it's trying to find. So, in one in one
task or one scenario, it might need a it
might be all the way over here. Uh in
another scenario, it might be over here.
And so forth.
Uh and to help the robot out a little
bit,
uh
we're going to going to introduce one
other thing, which is that there's going
to be
um like some piece of paper over here.
Uh and that paper actually says,
uh, where the object is, uh, in words.
Like it says that the object like, uh,
maybe it's trying to find, um, like a
replacement light bulb or something like
that. And it says the light bulb is in
like the fourth hallway
at the end.
Okay. Um, so here's our robot. Here are
the hallways. Um, different tasks
correspond to navigating to the ends of
the different halls. And we have some
information about where to go. And if we
look at that, um, it it information will
be in the state about where, uh,
where the reward is for this task.
Now,
how do we actually learn how to explore?
So, say that we were trying to collect
trajectories, uh, and trying to learn,
um, how to explore such that we can, um,
get a good, uh, get good behavior. So,
say that we
Let's start with the scenario where,
um, we sampled the task, and maybe the
task was to go to the end of this
hallway right here.
And say that we collected a,
um, we actually kind of just got lucky.
We collected a trajectory that just went
straight to
that reward.
Now, in some ways that seems good
because we got reward for that.
Uh, and so
that gave us, um, some reward.
Uh, and that's like optimizing the
objective that we care about ultimately
But the thing that's bad about this is
that
the robot doesn't like the robot got
lucky, and it doesn't actually
know how to repeat that in the future
because it, um, it didn't actually
explore any other alternatives.
And so this is going to be
the way that we can kind of view this is
that it goes to the end of the correct
hallway, it'll get positive reward, but
the context
leading up to getting that positive
reward doesn't actually look different
than any other task. Uh it kind of went
through here uh and it there's nothing
that it kind of differentiates
uh what it did there, which was like
zero reward, zero reward, um than if the
task, for example, had been to go here
or to go here.
Uh and as a result, I didn't actually
learn how to explore, and it didn't
learn how to use exploration information
in order to solve the task.
And so this trajectory might not might
not actually be very helpful for
learning um
for learning how to explore and learning
how to exploit.
Now, let's say that we had
a different uh a different trajectory.
So, we're exploring,
and let's say that the agent
uh
instead of doing that, uh it had it
maybe sampled the same task, uh and it
went to the end of this trajectory, and
then continued, didn't see that, and
then went to the end of this trajectory.
Um so, that would be good in the sense
that
it um it does actually have like it did
kind of rule out it it has experience
that ruled out one task, uh and now it
and then it got reward for a different
task. And so, it's going to be teaching
it something about an exploration
strategy that works.
The downside is that exploration
strategy is quite suboptimal, uh cuz it
would have been a lot more efficient to
then to first look at the instructions,
and then go to the correct position.
Uh and so, it's
somewhat good, somewhat bad. It provides
signal on a suboptimal exploration and
exploitation strategy,
uh and so, is perhaps a better better
than the first for trajectory that it
did, um but still not ideal.
Um now, let's consider a third
trajectory.
Uh say that we are again collecting data
for for uh the meta RL process, and
let's say that the agent
um
decided to like look at the instructions
and then just like stay and like watch
the instructions.
Does anyone have thoughts on like
whether that would be like a useful
trajectory or not for the learning
process?
Yeah, exactly. So, it did something
useful, but it doesn't get any reward
for that. Like it only gets rewarded
until it if it did that and then went
here.
And so, that's also not going to be very
useful for the learning problem.
And
basically you only like
in the problem like this, you're only
going to actually be getting good
like learning something useful about how
to explore and exploit if you
successfully
did the proper exploration behavior and
then did the exploitation behavior. And
if you do them in separate episodes,
then the
then you're not actually getting good
learning signal.
And that means that you sort of have
this kind of sample complexity where you
need to actually get lucky and do both
of the two things at the same time in
order to get signal that helps you learn
the problem.
So, basically it's hard to learn how to
explore and exploit at the same time.
Another way to another example of this
is say that you're trying to learn how
to cook.
You you have data in previous kitchens.
Your goal is to then be able to quickly
learn how to cook in a new kitchen.
Now, in order to learn how to cook, you
need to find the ingredients.
And if you haven't yet figured out how
to find the ingredients cuz you had bad
exploration,
then you can't learn how to cook
cuz you don't have the ingredients with
you. And then you're going to get low
reward.
And also, if you don't yet know how to
cook because you haven't like collected
experience on that, then regardless of
the exploration you do, you're going to
get low reward.
And so, you sort of have this chicken
and egg problem between learning how to
explore
and learning how to solve the task using
that information.
And so, there's you can way using this
this kind of coupling problem where
exploration and execution or
exploitation depend on each other in
order to be jointly successful.
So
then the way to view end-to-end training
is that
um it's great in that like you can learn
this optimal trade-off, but it can be
extremely challenging if you have a hard
exploration problem because you need to
figure out how to explore and exploit uh
and get learning signal uh that way.
Um the question is is the ultimate
challenge here that the reward is
sparse. So
it's true that if you had a dense
reward, you um you'd be in a much better
place uh because basically cuz you
wouldn't really have to explore. Uh you
yeah, you'd be able to
um
but you wouldn't have to explicitly take
actions to explore.
The um and this really comes down to a
problem when exploration is hard. If
exploration is easy, this really isn't a
problem cuz you you no longer have to
solve both exploration and exploitation,
you only have to solve exploitation.
So there's a couple solutions to this
and we'll start to talk about one
solution today
uh and then on Friday we'll talk about
uh more solutions.
So
the second solution and I'm not going to
go into like complete detail on how
these work, but one solution here is
instead of optimizing just for
end-to-end reward, you can add in
auxiliary exploration objectives to
encourage it to uh
to try to actually figure out something
um
more meaningful about the task.
Um one approach here is to use what's
called uh posterior sampling.
Um also called Thompson sampling.
And the the way that this works is that
uh we talked about
we talked about having um an algorithm
where you're trying to infer what the
task is.
And if you have
uh
if you've collected some experience so
far and you've inferred some
distribution over your task um in this
case ZI is now kind of some latent
representation. It's not uh a
representation that's known.
Then what you could do is you could then
uh sample
from this distribution and then
uh act as if that was kind of the
correct task.
So if you have um if if you have like
this task inference procedure and then
you also have a policy that given an
estimate of Z uh is able to
generate actions.
Then what you can do is you can sample a
Z from this distribution and then sample
from this policy.
And if you have policies that can that
are able to um this starts to kind of
get couple of the problem a little bit
because if you have policies that um for
a given Z are uh kind of do the task
then you would basically learn an
exploration strategy that is trying to
uh kind of go down the different um
the different uh
corridors uh
to find
uh the solution. So um as an example
this is actually a problem that looks
somewhat similar to the corridors where
you get a sparse reward um if you reach
one of these circles and the different
circles correspond to different tasks.
And in this case we've sampled this uh
this task right here.
And first we sample um a Z from our kind
of prior over tasks without any
uh any we haven't collected any data yet
so we sample Z we then run our policy
based on those different Zs and we get
exploration based on these.
And then we use that to infer what the
task might be. And so now we know that
the task is probably either over here or
over here.
And so now you'll collect trajectories
that are lighter in color that are like
this one, this one, and going over here.
And then once you actually collected
this trajectory, then you should
actually have a much narrower
distribution over the task cuz you get
positive reward here.
And so then you'll your policy or your Z
distribution will be narrowed out here
and you'll execute your policy according
to the Zs.
Um and so
that's kind of one approach for
addressing this exploration problem.
Uh basically learning this represent
this latent representation over tasks
and then sampling from those tasks from
that distribution and acting accordingly
according to your policy for that task.
Um does anyone have thoughts on like So
there's some scenarios where this is
great and scenarios where this is not so
great.
Um does anyone have thoughts on when
this sort of sampling might be bad? Like
what sort of MDPs this might not work
well in?
Uh if you have a large action space. Uh
that could contribute
uh
although it it isn't just having to do
with the action space cuz like if you
have a dense reward in a in a high large
action space you'd be probably okay.
So if Z is out of distribution cer-
certainly things will be problematic but
even in distribution there's scenarios
where
this exploration strategy will be like
really bad.
Yeah, so one So one scenario where this
might be work poorly is if
um
if you start to see like some um
some reward uh
but there might actually be even a even
better reward in another scenario. Uh
you might kind of start to exploit a
little bit too early. Um although it
won't rule out those those higher reward
scenarios if it knows that there are
other tasks that might have higher
rewards.
So I guess the kind of the scenario that
I was thinking of where I think that
this can be quite bad is
um is actually a lot like this scenario
right here. So, the strategy that
posterior sampling will learn in this
scenario is instead of looking at the
instructions, it's instead going to go
down each of the hallways and try to
find the reward.
Uh because it's trying to explicitly
explore by executing policies
corresponding to different tasks.
Uh and this would be especially bad if
the hallways are very long.
Uh so, if the hallways are really really
long like um I don't know, take days to
traverse, then what it's going to do is
it's going to spend days going down one
of them and then figuring out that it's
not the right one and then spend days
going down another one rather than
trying to seek out information that
might tell it about what to do.
Cool. So, um for example, if the goals
if these goals are very far away and
there's some sign that tells you what
the correct goal is, then um this is uh
a bad strategy. Now, if that sign
doesn't exist, uh then kind of it
actually would be a good strategy cuz
you have to go down those different
corridors.
Okay. Um there's a couple of other
approaches that we can use as well uh
that include intrinsic adding intrinsic
rewards that try to
um encourage it to visit new states uh
and also trying to visit states that
help you distinguish the dynamics and
reward models for different tasks.
Um so, we try to collect data so that
our model of rewards and states are
accurate. Um and with this sort of
approach, you can actually get
exploration strategy that looks a lot
more efficient, that looks something
like this compared to posterior sampling
that's trying to uh kind of just sample
the different uh trajectories for the
different tasks.
Um there's also scenarios where this
might be bad um if there's lots of
distractors um or really complex state
dynamics. Um
but fortunately, don't have too much
time to go over that now. So, these
sorts of approaches are easier to
optimize than end-to-end. A lot of them
have some principle behind them uh but
they can be very suboptimal in certain
environments and it kind of depends on
the environment or the domain.